[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
200 Biggins
so does uh
some other gang
one of the other defendants turns
themselves in and Georgia showed us John
Eastman
Donald Trump's preparing to turn himself
in on Thursday under the conditions that
he cannot intimidate a witness on social
media good luck with that [__]
good luck with you know I I want to back
up a bit here I said a few weeks ago you
know everyone was talking about cameras
in the federal courtroom and how chetkin
was gonna arrest him and jail him and
this and that and I told you then I said
look the state court down in Georgia
that's where you're going to get the
circus more than you are in the federal
court
especially with jetkin jetkin is not
going to run a circus she's not going to
allow her court room to be a circus but
Georgia state law seems to be set up to
where we could have the real Trump clown
show here
now the judge setting conditions of his
bail that he cannot intimidate or repost
repost
people intimidating Witnesses
so he can't retruth it on fraud social
this is significant this is significant
turn of events now I know everyone's
excited about Grandpa getting arrested
again and turning himself into an actual
jail and getting you know his mug shot
getting processed the way that every
other criminal does in Georgia alleged
Criminal
alleged
but this all comes on the heels
of the presidential debate tomorrow
night in the Republican primary which is
listen this is going to go over like a
wet fart in a white thong tomorrow
all the Medias oh they're really hyped
up about this they're like oh man this
is gonna be great no it's not it is not
going to be great what is going to be
clear is that Chris Christie should be
the nominee but he's not going to be Ron
DeSantis should have never entered the
race and he should get out now and Vivek
ramaswamy is a God damn plant for Trump
that's all it's going to tell us that's
the only thing oh yeah and all the other
people are ill relevant
they shouldn't they shouldn't even be
running for president in the first place
that's all it's going to tell us the
[__] we already know
these are things we already know folks
tomorrow night is not going to give us
any any revelation
Garen goddamn tea it
these people are not going to change
what they're doing
it's not gonna happen Ronda Santos is
gonna say woke God knows how many
[__] times he's gonna look like a
goddamn idiot doing it Chris Christie is
gonna bash him while he's doing it it's
gonna make Ron DeSantis look feeble and
weak
vivec is going to continue to say
people's names over and over and over
Christy Chris Christie Chris Christie
Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron that's
what he's gonna do and he's gonna
continue to send for Trump
and when asked when asked the only one
on stage that is going to [__] refuse
to say that they would that they would
pardon Trump because this is gonna be a
question on the stage will you pardon
Trump if you become president that's
gonna that's gonna be a [__] question
in the Republican primary where the
front runner who wants to be pardoned by
the next president he that's why he's
running himself so he can pardon himself
that's the whole [__] oh my God
and and people
sometimes you know
brush it off when I say we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life
the [__] you think I'm talking about
look at the timeline look at this stupid
ass timeline that we have here
there's not one not one serious person
gonna be standing on stage not [__]
one
well what about Chris Christie no Chris
Christie's there for other reasons than
to be a serious person if Chris Christie
really was a serious person he wouldn't
be engaged in this activity
he wouldn't be
he wouldn't he would wait till next time
I think that's actually what he's doing
is he's setting up a position so he can
run in 2028 Chris Christie has been a
master of this for many many years where
he has positioned himself where he can
he can run
Rhonda santis is not a master of that
Rhonda Santos has destroyed his
political career and tomorrow night will
be an exclamation point on that
you can guaran goddamn tea it
because if Trump not being there he
won't be able to destroy him but Chris
Christie surely will absolutely dress
down and [__] make a fool of Ron
DeSantis
and Rhonda Santos should be terrified of
Chris Christie absolutely terrified I
don't know how they're prepping him for
Chris Christie or if they are but
tomorrow night is Rhonda santis is going
to be one of the bloodiest [__]
leaving the stage
because Chris Christie knows one thing
and one thing only Chris Christie has to
win New Hampshire he has to
and the only way to do that is take
advantage and make Ron DeSantis look
like a [__] loser
and do that while while DeSantis is
simping for Trump
so what's gonna happen
now I'm not gonna watch the whole thing
there's no need to
there's no need to watch the whole thing
trust me don't go give Fox News the
[__] ratings number one number two
we're we're gonna see all we need to see
uh when when Chris Christie bashes Trump
and Chris Christie destroys Ron DeSantis
and it's apparent from the clips of the
VEC that he's a goddamn Trump plant in
this race
did you know did you know that vivec is
as George Soros scholar recipient
[Laughter]
money from the Soros
that's a real [__] thing I'm not
kidding you that's a real thing
vivec is a goddamn Soros plant in the
Republican primary can you imagine no
what it is what it is is for vivec to be
the only one that Trump wants to debate
to and and Trump's going to say it in
the coming months vivek's the only one
that can beat me
and then as soon as they need to take
out the trash on vivec they're going to
take out the trash on him and the trash
is gonna be that he's a foreigner and
he's a Soros back candidate that's what
they're gonna say watch hide and [__]
watch
oh they got a huge plan they got a huge
plan to rise Vivek star and destroy him
and it's all laid out right in front of
you you can see it plain as day and
tomorrow it's going to make it even more
obvious that that's what's going on
but you know tomorrow tomorrow Rhonda
Santos's political career will finally
will finally be coming to an end and I'm
excited about that I told you the reason
why I wanted Ron DeSantis in this race
in the first place is to destroy his
political career at [__] feckless
fascist
[__] him
I can't I can't even tell you how how
dire it is for the State of Florida to
get rid of his ass
maybe maybe maybe just maybe they'll
recall him after he drops out of the
race because it's clear he didn't want
to be governor of Florida
he just wanted to use Florida as his
little stomping ground to make sure that
manga supporters thought he was the next
Hitler
that way he could rise to power take
over the federal government and make it
a fascist state
because he's a [__] bonehead
the good news is is he's a horrible
retail politician horrible absolutely
he's a [__] weirdo
good for him
good on oh good on you Ron good on you
you dumb [__] you should have
you should have resigned your your
governorship and got in the race three
months before you did and really started
punching on Donald Trump you [__]
you goddamn [__]
ain't ain't none of these [__]
nothing but cowards
even Chris Christie yes I said it Chris
Christie's a coward too
where the [__] was Chris Christie he he
keeps saying the the day he turned on
Trump and he became anti-trump is the
night of the election when Trump came
out in front of a microphone and said
what he said about oh we won we didn't
lose before he even knew
well where were you Chris where were you
where were you punching on him huh
why weren't you calling national press
conferences why weren't you telling why
weren't you telling the world what you
learned
about Trump being so close to him why
not a goddamn peep the same way they
they act like Liz Cheney ain't no
goddamn coward Liz Cheney's a coward too
oh but Tony she was on the January 6th
select committee oh she did the bare
minimum of telling the [__] truth
good for her that's no [__] hero not
in my book
it took Liz Cheney 190 days to come to
the floor of the house to say that
Donald Trump lost
190 days
that's not a hero that's cowardice
it it took Mitch McConnell last days to
say that Donald Trump lost on the floor
of the Senate
think about that for a second think
about that let that settle in on you
just a bit
when you go to watch this debate
tomorrow night
when they when they [__] cower to
Trump who's not even there
you'll see him cower to Trump
you're gonna watch it
even Chris Christie's gonna say [__]
like well Trump did well on the economy
I mean we he had good power I mean he
wants the Trump policies Chris Christie
don't shake that out right
Chris Christie's just a hell of a lot
better retail politician than Ron
DeSantis could ever dream of
can you imagine what trouble we would be
in if Ron DeSantis had the retail
politics of Chris Christie oh we'd be
[__]
we'd be [__] because there'd be a real
fight for this nomination
and they may just choose someone who can
actually take over and make us a fascist
state
Donald Trump's only running for himself
that's that's that's selfishness that is
perpetuating his run for president of
the United States
Ronda santis truly believes truly
believes that he can turn this nation
into a fascist state
[__] Donald Trump doesn't know what a
fascist state is
he probably couldn't even Define what
fascism is
even though he is one
but here we are in this moment in
history
in this week
think about the uniqueness think think
about think about how we will look back
from 40 years from now it's either going
to be one or two ways folks
we're going to look back on this this
week in history
40 50 years from now there's only one or
two there's no there's only two
possibilities either we are going to
look back and go what in the [__] was
wrong with us how in the [__] did we get
in a situation where where the front
runner didn't even have to show up for
the Republican primary debate
and he was gonna be arrested on and
released on a 200 000 Bond the very next
day on state charges state criminal Rico
charges
in the state of Georgia
and that's not the first indictment
that's the fourth
he's a [__] criminal and a crook and
he's the front runner and didn't have to
show up to be the front runner
what the [__] was wrong with us that's
one and I guess the answer is gonna be
well they were a cult
that's gonna be the answer to history is
going to tell you know that right
oh yeah [__] history is gonna tell
that the Republican party and Maca was a
cult
and hopefully history will tell the
story of us speaking out against it
because the other option is not a good
option
is that 40 50 years from now Trump's
picture is still hanging in town squares
on big banners they're having military
parades hailing Trump
[__] doubt me do it at your own peril
what other what other outcomes do you
see happening
do you think we're gonna look back in
this time period and go you know we
really had our country really had our
[__] together
it's gonna be weird because we're gonna
be like well there was the the most
efficient effective competent president
that we've seen in modern times
he got the most done with the least
amount of people in Congress
no that's not what we're gonna look back
and see unfortunately I wish that was
I wish that was
do we look back do we look back during
the Civil Rights era
and do we hail the the great country
that we no
we look
at the troubles that we went through the
struggle that our country has had
that's what we look to
to tell us why why we should progress to
the Future
why diversity Equity inequality is a
damn good thing for our democracy it's
what will keep it to survive
for not just us here now but future
Generations that's what will keep
democracy in this country
we know that we see it in our history
and we can only look to the to
the times
where we had the most struggle of
finding ourselves of finding who we were
Jesus Christ there was a woman shot and
killed in California in her clothes in
her clothing store because she had a
certain flag
and some [__] daily wire Charlie Kirk
Sean Hannity Fox News watching
[__]
some Matt Walsh type goes in and [__]
kills her because of her flag
I want to point out I want I want just
to point out that in Ohio
not but a few months ago there were a
bunch of [__] Nazis walking around
with Nazi Flags which should not be
tolerated in this [__] country no one
was shooting at them
they were allowed to spread their hate
they were allowed to speak their hate
the guy that shot the [__] the the
lady in California the mother of nine
children just a a shop owner she just
owned a shop she has a right to put a
[__] pride flag in the shop if she
wants she can put a Nazi flag in the
shop if she wants
the party of freedom of speech wants to
kill not just the lgbtq community but
allies
public allies of that community and he
did he [__] killed her
terrorism their [__] terrorists and
Matt Walsh the daily wire are
responsible for it so is Nick Fuentes so
is Fox News
Charlie Kirk turning points USA every
[__] one of these white Christian
nationalists are responsible for that
[__] woman's death and their blood is
on their hands come [__] sue me you
[__] do it
I'm telling you it's their fault
they've spread this hate
and you don't think we're gonna look
back 50 years from now
and go what in the [__] were we thinking
who in the [__] put these people in
charge of this [__]
we did
this is a goddamn Republic it is a
democracy where we select our
Representatives
and it is high time that we engage in
our democracy in a way that [__]
shames people shames these [__]
nazi-ass Republicans
gonna get on stage and [__] Cow Town
to Trump tomorrow night that's what
they're gonna do they're gonna count how
to hate
what's their [__] platform what what
that they that they don't like gay
people that's their [__] platform
that's what Rhonda santis is gonna say
woke
and I don't like gay people woke
well you could throw black people in
there too because we definitely don't
like them historically
racist [__] [__] bigots
that's all they are oh Tony you can't
say that they're gonna have a black man
on stage oh cause that's not pre-planned
the [__] out of here
what do you take us for a bunch of dumb
asses no that's not no
we see what's going on
but when we look back in history that's
what we're gonna see why do you think I
speak so highly against it someone said
the other day in a comment they said
Tony doesn't [__] simply Biden I
don't
how many times do you hear me mention
the for the the current president of the
United States and hail his
accomplishments his accomplishments
speak for themselves I don't need to sit
here and [__] hold him on a goddamn
pedestal
unfortunately his history will be
remembered but it will be remembered
quietly
what we will remember is the [__] I talk
about every single day because it is the
true threat to our democracy the
Democratic party is not a [__] threat
to our democracy it's not a threat to
your diversity it's not a threat to your
Liberty
do they have some bad ideas sure why not
every part they always have
they've changed them throughout the
years some of them good some of them bad
some policy good some policy bad
but they're not wanting to end democracy
they're not wanting to end your ability
to have a say in your Liberty
these [__] standing on stage
tomorrow
are gonna be complacent to hate
they're going to be complacent to
stripping away your rights to your
[__] Health Care your daughter's
Health Care your [__] mother your
sister's Health Care
they're going to be complacent on on
your choice
for your children to get educated in
this country to the truth
what do you [__] think the threat of
democracy is huh
I'm telling you
and I'll say it loudly and proudly
if we don't stand in their way now 40 50
years from now our history will not tell
the truth and we need it to tell the
truth
this week's going to be an exciting week
oh boy Grandpa's gonna get arrested
again we're probably gonna get a mug
shot
he's going to be out on two hundred
thousand dollars Bond
on a bail bond he's gonna be out
he's not going to be able to intimidate
people on social media at least that's
what the judge says we'll see if the
judge holds to that because that's the
question
will the judge hold him to it will they
[__] jail him
but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if they'll jail him
you know that right
it doesn't matter if he breaks his bail
it doesn't matter they're going to
nominate him
it's Insanity it seems like something
that you couldn't even make up
but it's here and it's now
and we have to stand in the way of
fascism because it's not just him he's a
symptom of the [__] issue
the issue is that the Republican party
is a cult of hate
and tomorrow night you'll find that out
when you see these clips of this debate
that is all it's going to be is a cult
of hate
and they are going to capitulate
to the bigotry of the Republican Party
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe I
doubt it
that Brett Bear won't ask the question
about the shop owner in California
that was gunned down because of a of a
pride flag
because that woman has the freedom of
speech she has the right to hang a pride
flag in her shop
that's something she has the right to do
what will he ask
will he ask the question
no he won't ask the question they can't
answer it
they can't
because they have to be the weapon of
hatred
just remember that
just remember as we we excitedly hail
and celebrate that Donald Trump is
arrested again
and he's still out wandering around
spreading his hate
to his in his victimhood oh my God
the [__] whining is just gonna get
worse and worse and worse
especially after tomorrow it's gonna get
worse
so after tomorrow it's going to be clear
that no one else is going to be able to
compete with him you know that right
the media doesn't even see it like they
don't even see it yet I see it
tomorrow's gonna be the the [__]
beginning of trump being the nominee
it's what's gonna happen
Ron DeSantis is no longer going to be
number two
it's going to be clear that Chris
Christie's the only one willing to fight
Trump and it is going to damage him
in the Maga cult in the Republican cult
and the only other outlier that seems to
have some sort of chance fivec
is is going to be put in second place
and then within months right before Iowa
he's going to be destroyed it's a Soros
plant
that's what's gonna happen
but don't take my word for it go watch
it and then keep watching the show here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central for two
full hours on YouTube don't forget to
subscribe on YouTube
we're getting more subscribers every
single day more watches holy [__] we're
up like 58 or something in views
something like that something like that
if you want to get in on the venmo chat
you know we don't have super chat here
on YouTube a lot of people like the
super chat but YouTube hates my [__]
guts that's just the way it goes so if
you want to get on the venmo chat you
can get the QR code there just rewind
pause get the QR code or you can go to
the Tony michaels.com that's right you
can go to the Tony michaels.com the
venmo chat link is at the top send me a
message I'll put it up on the screen
during the show
you know then it's Tuesday and I I don't
see um
I don't see Texas Paul yet so I'm gonna
have to um I'm gonna have to message him
see if he's uh still still good for
today I thought he was uh the Discord
chat's going crazy today where's the
chat party at it's on Discord it never
stops let's see let me let me give you
the link in the chat this is the correct
Discord link now that way you guys can
go over and join the Discord
it's really it's crazy over there if you
if you like the the chant
if you like the chat here on YouTube or
on Twitch or anywhere with the [__]
fam you're gonna love the Discord
it's over there 24 7. it's where the
chant never stops uh there's plenty of
people talking right now in the live
show chat that's where they chat at
during the show is in the live show chat
they even stream the show over there too
so you can watch it on Discord as you're
chatting
Texas Paul says no link I emailed it uh
maybe it didn't uh let's see send again
there you go there's your no that's not
that's the wrong one no wonder no wonder
that's the wrong one hang on hang on
Paul hang on Paul yeah
Texas pause in the chat he's like no
link you know I I tried to email it
maybe it didn't go through
here
I hope I hope that one went through if
not I'll I'll text it to you everyone
stick around we're gonna get Texas Paul
the link we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
mark
seconds the
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
I think I finally have the email I'm
gonna tell you something so you know I
said YouTube [__] hates my gut oh my
God they hate me okay so we started this
broadcast just 30 minutes ago and 22
minutes in uh YouTube Community
guidelines there's age restricted this
episode already we're not even we're not
we're not even halfway through and
YouTube's like ah we're gonna age
restrict this thing
do you see what I go through oh my God
people like you know what you should do
what you should do is you stop cussing
Tony I'm like look are you kidding me
have you have any idea no one would come
watch me no one if I calm down and stop
cussing I don't think anyone I don't
think in one person I'd be like well
Tony doesn't curse anymore you kidding
me why would we go watch that guy this
guy has profanity poetry down to a T why
would we go watch Tony Michaels without
the
profanity profanity poetry I believe I'm
really good
and profanity I think I'm really good
you think I'm Really Gonna I know you
guys think I'm really good at it
I'm pretty goddamn good at putting some
curse words together I'm not gonna lie
but the I'm I'm dead serious I just got
an email I had to email Paul the the
link he's here he's going to be here I'm
just hanging I want the audience to hang
at brother Texas Paul is going to be or
not and I don't think Gabe's gonna be
able to join us today so it's just me in
Texas Paul today
um but seriously at 11 22 I got an email
from from YouTube I'm looking at it
right now on my phone then I got a
community guidelines uh
um uh restriction on my content it's age
restricted
so you have to be 18 years of age uh to
watch today's episode
which you probably should be anyways to
be quite honest I mean
there's all kinds of things we could
talk about Texas Paul and
uh age-restricted stuff is gonna be some
of them I'm sure here on the Tony
Michaels podcast welcome Texas ball
um I don't know what happened with the
email I'm not really sure but I'm glad
you're here
I'm glad to be here my friend I'm glad
to be here I was just I was just
patiently waiting on I knew eventually
it'd show up I I emailed it
about an hour ago but you know it
happens it happens you're here on here
everyone else is here this is the
important thing Texas Paul this is going
to be historic week
it's gonna be a story like I mean we're
gonna we're gonna see stuff that um we
haven't seen before even with the first
three indictments it's it sounds like
we're gonna get a mug shot it sounds
like he's actually gonna have to put up
money for bail
um but the most important thing here is
the the actual uh bail restrictions
I think we're gonna see if Donald Trump
actually has the ability to remain
silent we know he has the right but I
just don't believe he has the ability
right I think that's going to be the the
question here whether he can stop his
fingers from intimidating Witnesses
whether it's to repost or to post uh on
on fraud social what do you think
I don't I don't think it's like that old
Ron White joke I had the right to remain
silent but I didn't have the ability
yeah yeah hey man did you you know there
wasn't any White House china for Trump
right I mean because they they were
trying to uh Melania went way over the
job she didn't meet the deadlines
um um the you know the White House
Historical Society pays for all that and
then she requested such over the top
amounts of China that they just you know
they said no and then they finally had a
hit walk away so we have no Trump China
right well
they've came through
um Trump doing that old Roger Stone
thing you know just seemed inevitable
declare victory has asked Picard uh Fine
China of Antioch to go ahead and produce
some samples of his new China so Picard
sent to the white house uh historical
Association some samples of the you know
what would be the 2024 Trump China and
uh I I since I'm a friend of the
Historical Society I got a copy of it
is that the Department of Corrections in
Georgia huh
well you know I I I'm gonna tell you
because
um
I actually don't think he's gonna be
able to keep to these uh bear
restrictions right I just I just don't
see it and and even if he can even if he
can I I
think he's gonna go right up to the line
right
but the question is if he does break the
bail conditions the restrictions what's
his punishment I mean that that's the
real question here right that's what
everyone is kind of like laying in the
bushes waiting to see if this idiot
really does do what we think he's going
to do which is keep his mouth
continually moving and not not doing
what he should do is just shut the [__]
up and move along
but what is the judge gonna do because
the judge clearly clearly is uh putting
restrictions on his bail to make it very
difficult for Trump
well yeah I mean it was McAfee if I'm
remembering correctly it was Judge
McAfee I mean he laid it out for him it
was pretty straightforward it was don't
say anything to intimidate Witnesses or
anything participating in the trial uh
any of your co-defendants or Witnesses
and then he came out and said
um
oh God what was the other caveat there I
just I had just had it in my mind it was
blanked out but anyways he he laid it
out there I mean perfectly that you that
that you know you cannot do the [__]
you've been oh yeah you can't link
anybody else's threats either that
doesn't work I mean you you just can't
do it just the the fact that you don't
say it doesn't matter if you link on
your social media threats from other
people
that counts as a threat
um and there's no way in hell
Trump is going to be able to control
himself he's just not going to be able
to do it as the news breaks you know he
sits there and he watches
TV he like claims to be mad at Fox but
he watches Fox continuously as soon as
something breaks you know it he's going
to come out and he's going to start
banging away with them little fat little
tiny you know round nub thumbs of his
and
it you know it's going to be right in
McAfee's lap he's gonna have to he's
going to have to
he's gonna have to react yes I mean they
when he laid it out so clearly I mean he
just made made himself
what's the word I'm looking for I mean
he's gonna look like a eunuch man if he
doesn't do anything
so you know it's a question rather it's
a question rather uh a judge is actually
going to to jail him right like that's
the question because Chet can everyone
expected chetkin when he started to
repost [__] about Georgia and he started
to really Yap his trap about George
everyone's like oh he's breaking laws
intimidating Witnesses and chutkin his
Bear release was that if he breaks any
state laws then she's gonna you know
remand him which she didn't not at all
not him close and I knew she wouldn't
but here we have a unique situation
because federal court is different than
state court now generally speaking
report generally speaking courts do not
want you they don't they don't want to
jail you they don't want they will but
they don't want to federal courts do net
and do not want to jail you that's the
last thing they want to do and the
reason why is because federals the
federal system doesn't have jails right
they don't they don't have a jail they
got a contract with County county jails
and other state jails um to actually
jail their their defendants right and
sometimes it's years sometimes if they
have to if they have to jail a defendant
it takes three four years before that
that defendant is ever in trial it takes
a long time sometimes if in the federal
system so they don't want you they don't
want to jail that's why they don't
really do Bond conditions as far as like
money they don't make you put up they're
like no we want you to be out we want
you to be working we want you to be some
sort of productive member of society
while you're waiting on your trial
because they just don't have a jail
system they have a prison system they'll
put your ass in prison trust me but they
don't have a jail system but the state
has a jail system the states have jails
the County Prosecutors have a jail that
they can [__] detain you in so
it's a little different in the state
those judges think differently than a
federal judge when they're talking about
pre-trial detainment and pre-trial
awaiting pre-trial for the trial like
they think differently the state the
state's judges do and there's different
state laws based on bail and stuff as
well so I always saw that Georgia was
probably the best opportunity if Trump
is going to sit in a jail cell like I
thought that's probably the best
opportunity to see him sit in a jail
cell and it seems like that's going to
play out possibly I I you know I don't
know what the judge is going to do
though
well you know I don't mean to disappoint
Anybody Everybody wants to see him just
swept off to jail immediately but you
know in any you know this Tony they
don't start with jail I mean they they
start with a verbal warning they'll
bring you before the judge and talk
Stern to you then they go to fines and
then after fines if you keep them in
your nose he'll get three strikes at
this at least but but in my humble
opinion he'll get three strikes at this
at least they're not going to go
straight to okay put them in cuffs and
take them to jail I mean because that
that just gives him
a beautiful opportunity
to file for appeal he's going to file
for appeal anyways but I mean that one
will stand out well look they poisoned
the jury pool before we could even
select a jury by locking me in jail so
they're going to be very reticent
is especially before the jury's chosen
because they can sequester the jury but
the the you know they they're going to
be very very
reticent to to to act sternly against
Trump pre-trial so that he doesn't have
that appeal uh Avenue to say well the
jewelry pool was poisoned against me
well he's not going to start with well I
think that's going to be his appeal
process anyways whether it's in the
appeal court or in the state court
that's that's going to be his go-to
anyways is that I mean that's what he's
already doing when he's like trying to
change venue and [__] like that I mean
what is he going to do in Fulton County
is he going to try to change the venue
Mark Meadows has already tried it Mark
benos is trying to change the venue from
a a County Courthouse to a federal
courthouse now that doesn't mean that
that D.A Willis and the state won't be
prosecuting under state law it just
means that Mark Meadows is betting that
that a federal judge will be more fair
in a courtroom and the reason why that
is is because again a federal courtroom
a Federal Criminal courtroom is
different than a state criminal
courtroom it's completely different it's
not it's not the same thing and it
doesn't operate the same way that's why
there's no cameras in a federal [__]
criminal courtroom is because of how it
operates and it's different it's just
different and Mark Meadows wants to get
this in a federal courtroom and the
reason why is because I think Mark
Meadows has a deal with Jack Smith and
the bets
um and and fonnie Willis the D.A of
Fulton County doesn't give a [__] about
that deal that he's been given she does
not give a [__] she does not give a [__]
about that deal that was given to Mark
Meadows and Mark Meadows is in a tough
position here and I actually think that
some of the Jack Smith's case
honest honestly in my personal opinion A
lot of people won't like that I say this
I don't know that you will either I
actually believe that phony Willis not
giving a [__] that Mark Meadows has a
deal with Jack Smith I actually think
hurts Jack Smith's case and the reason
why is because if Mark Meadows thinks
he's actually going to go to prison no
matter what Mark Meadows may say well
I'm not going to [__] cooperate [__]
you I'm not going to be known as the one
who turned on Trump if if I don't get
the immunity then I that I'm so afforded
you know that that Mark Meadows is
definitely an entitled [__] or
do you think I'm just off my rock no no
I I think you're spot on there I think
that they can easily piss all over each
other's cases right you know how complex
this is you know the negotiations with
these Witnesses because you make your
you make absolutely the correct point
there
um if Mark Meadows says you know if I'm
going to jail down in Fulton County you
know if I'm going to sweat it out in a
state prison down in Georgia right screw
this man I want to go to a I want to go
to a federal community is where I want
to go but
with the things that have kind of
unfolded and the things that they have
come out with what he said I've actually
walked back my belief that he's actually
participate he's actually cooperating
um wait wait see you think you think
Mark Meadows isn't cooperating with Jack
Smith in the federal the federal
authorities
no I think he's an arrogant jackass who
thinks that he's playing games with Jack
Smith and and you know there's a deal on
the table but he thinks he's smarter
than the rest of the world and is trying
to work this and and if you look at his
like for instance he says I do not
recall Trump ever uh declassifying any
documents uh
that's not saying
Trump never in my presence ever tried to
deny you know you know that that's
that's two different statements I do not
recall is what Ronald Reagan said his
entire you know to keep his at his ass
out of jail over Iran Contra and this
didn't happen in my presence are two
very different statements correct and
and I do not recall is not necessarily
the the testimony you would expect out
of somebody who's cooperating with
the prosecutors because
that's not how they would frame that I
mean they just would not they would say
did Donald Trump ever in your presence
you were his chief of staff you were
with him all the time you facilitated
his requests and desires to the point of
even traveling down to Georgia
did he ever tell you we're declassifying
documents the answer there is no not
I do not recall you know that that to me
just I don't know Tony that smacks to me
like he's still playing freaking games
and
don't know that Bonnie Willis and Jack
Smith aren't actually dancing together
and Jack Smith is sitting there saying
do you want my deal where you go to Club
fed and you have tennis courts what do
you want Buddy's deal wow where you go
bus route in Georgia you know with no
air conditioning can't can't fed can't
fed always gets this glorious reputation
that these federal prison cancer just
you know like cushy hotels or something
and I I Reish I will reassure you they
they definitely are not the tennis court
sucks
um the tennis scores sucks but here's
but here's what I here's what I will
tell you is that I I guaran them to you
that if Mark Meadows is playing his
cards here and he's like if I gotta do
time I'm gonna do time in a federal
prison camp that's where I want to do
time and the reason why is because if
Mark Meadows is charged and convicted in
Georgia
and they sentence him in Georgia let's
say they sentenced him to two or three
years which is likely the case right
something like that and and he goes to
Federal Court they're probably going to
probably charge him convict him if he
gets if he gets charged and he gets
indicted a jury will convict him and
then the judge would probably give him
the same amount of time in a federal
prison right now when if he goes if he
gets convicted in both jurisdictions
he's gonna serve the federal time first
there's no way that the the feds are
going to let him go to a Georgia State
Prison they're not going to do that and
the Georgia state officials don't have
any choice when the feds pick you up
that's it you can have him after we're
done with him it's kind of the attitude
with with the feds now here's the thing
is that those two those two sentences
will coincide with each other so as he's
serving time in a federal prison Georgia
has to take that time off his sentencing
in other words let's say his time is
three years in Georgia and three years
in the FED if he serves three years in
the bed he won't serve any time in a
Georgia penitentiary
he'll serve all his Georgia time in a
federal penitentiary and that's how it
works that's how it works and and so so
Mark Meadows is doing that doing that um
it's what's the worst case scenario for
me right because you know like you said
he's entitled he thinks he's going to
get out of this Mark Meadows definitely
thinks he can talk his way out of his
that that's why the whole documents
thing because Mark Meadows doesn't want
to be indicted in the documents case and
he really doesn't want to be [__]
involved in it at all that's why Mark
Meadows turned evidence when he gave the
Feds that [__] interview with his
biographer right like he's like yeah
Trump did an interview and he was
[__] showing documents and Mark
Meadows is like I'm not involved in it I
just haven't even evidence against him
and that's where I think Mark Meadows is
trying to make a deal if you want to
know the you know if that's if that's
what I'm thinking right that's where
he's trying to turn evidence well you
know he's also looking at you know this
you know this Tony you when you the the
the deal with Federal time is he has the
opportunity as somebody to go to one of
the nicer prisons in the federal system
and there are some nicer prisons in the
federal systems
but they're pretty well I mean there's
only I think there's only three three
Federal camps in the country that
actually have a fence around it that
there's one uh the one that Rod begovich
was in in Colorado that's an old hotel
the one in South Dakota that's that's a
university it used to be a college
campus it's it's now a federal prison
and a lot of times you can't even tell
they're actually a first prison uh
prison camp unless you look at the sign
like it doesn't it doesn't look like a
[__] prison a lot of times and a lot
of times they have the camps near
a very big uh facility and the reason
why is because they have the camp the
people in the camp the prisoners in the
camp take care of the grounds of the
bigger prison that this child works
because why would they hire anyone when
they could use slave labor you know they
could use Excuse me prison labor excuse
me but you know I mean that's that's the
upside of the federal time the downside
of the federal time is you do your time
if you're convicted federally there
isn't this oh wide behavior and we're
going to let you out really quick now
you get a little you get a little bit of
good time
it's not a lot it's not a lot uh it's
not a lot of good time they don't get
and they don't there's no parole uh in
the federal system there's no getting
out early on parole that's not what
happens you're I believe it's something
like
if you do everything perfectly in
federal prison and you qualify as
somebody that they will actually give
good time to
it's like 85 you will serve 85 percent
of your time well most people it's nine
for ten you know I mean it's and the
other thing too is they they let people
out of uh federal prison early to go to
like a halfway house
um and and halfway house is actually
still considered your federal
confinement whether you're at a halfway
house or you're at home on an ankle
monitor it's still considered part of
your federal imprisonment and Bop
actually is the one who who
administrates that right so yeah so a
lot of times you'll see people getting
out of federal prison with an ankle like
Michael uh Cohen got out of federal
prison an anchor monitor he he was not
he was actually being detained by Bop at
that point with that ankle monitor and
they were using uh pre-trial agents and
and probation officers probably to
administrate that uh confinement with
the Bureau of Prisons
um but it's they're not under the the
the probation offices jurisdiction at
that point even though they're
administrating that confinement by The
Bureau prisons so it's real confusing
and the reason why again is because the
federal the federal system doesn't have
jails if you live in a state
um and you're like your county has a
contract with the feds and you're
wondering like why is the jail so full
in our County well a lot of times it's
because your county is the one that's
contracted to Jail the defendants that
the feds have for three damn counties
right and they ship them to this one
damn County jail for three damn counties
you know and that's how they do it
because the feds pay for these people to
be incarcerated in a jail while they
await trial that's why the feds don't
necessarily want to do that because it
costs [__] money it costs money to
jail these people uh even though they
don't do a good job how how satisfying
would it be though Paul seeing the
pictures and the images from the Fulton
County jail because it's a [__]
oh yeah oh my gosh
about going to jail in folk County how
how how [__] sweet would it be that
Donald Donald Trump would have to spend
a couple nights in the Fulton County
Jail
how freaking sweet would it be that he
had to actually serve his term in the
Georgia State Penitentiary
I mean that is so so this brings up a
good question I think it's a question
that everyone's probably asking
themselves and I've been asking myself
this for a long time because I don't
know exactly how they're going to
incarcerate a former president as Secret
Service detail he's entitled to it being
a former president so I'm not really
sure about this yet but here's the thing
if if he is jailed what what do they do
with the Secret Service what do they do
about his detail I mean do you see I I
just can't figure this out I know this
question is probably Weighing on the
minds of a lot of people including
Donald Trump like how how do I do they
stay in the cell with me does their
shifts do they stand outside to sell you
know what what's the deal
uh he loses his secret service
protection he doesn't lose the right to
it but the secret service at that point
will turn his security over to the the
prison itself I mean just because you're
under Secret Service protection doesn't
mean that that secret service has to be
the people that are standing next to you
um what will happen is that whatever
prison he sent to the the warden will
send documentation to the Secret Service
that says I promise on my honor we will
do everything we can to ensure the
safety of Donald Trump including keeping
him in his own sale in a bucket 24 hours
a day uh but he will lose his the yeah
secret service is not going to prison
with him they are not
so so how do we get past the fact that
we afford a former president Secret
Service detail then how do we get past
that
because he's entitled to it rather you
rather whether you like it or not he's
entitled to it that's part of this it's
a Curtis it's a courtesy and it's not up
to him it's up to the current
Administration and Secret Service
themselves what protection they want to
afford this President it's not like you
owe me no it's it's you don't think
that's what he's gonna say oh yeah he's
going to feel that way come on I mean
that's that's what I'm saying it's like
what's the protest from this [__]
chucklehead right let's say let's say
let's say on Thursday he goes in he's
he's arraigned on his Rico charges
and let's say by next week the [__]
idiot is on true social and the judge
has to send out the marshals to go get
this some [__] wherever he's at at
Bedminster Mar-A-Lago or wherever the
hell he's going to be they got to go get
him because he just he just can't keep
his [__] mouth shut
so the judge is going to slap him in
jail for a couple days on contempt uh to
for for violating his bail conditions
and maybe he doesn't revoke the whole
Bond but maybe he just you know
reprimands him because he can do that he
can do pretty much whatever they want at
that point once you're indicted and
you're out on bail
they can do almost anything they want
but what do you what do you think
what do you think is the reaction from
Maga do you think they're gonna go to
the Fulton County Jail and you know with
pitchforks you think that's oh they're
going to protest their asses off yeah
yeah you got those hard you got that
hardcore
cult it's like any cult you've got the
periphery people that are believer oh
yeah I love the cult leader and oh this
is wonderful you know you've got those
people then you've got the freaking
people that are like
right and when when Trump Goes to Jail
yeah you're going to get a lot of really
stupid people doing really stupid [__]
but they're gonna they're they're gonna
go to jail man I mean it's it's that
simple they're gonna go with their cult
leader to jail you know it's like when
they took Warren Jeffs to jail I mean
you they that they stood outside and had
their little prayer thing as he drove by
and you're gonna have all that man you
are you're gonna have all of that
nonsense going on well it's going to be
wonderful let me let me show you this
guy this is wild
this is wild [__] what I you know maybe
we'll have some of these boneheads show
up listen to this anybody took a Pfizer
it's owned by Pfizer anybody taking
moderna is owned by moderna and they're
calling the species Borg Genesis it's
not even a human anymore it's called
board Genesis but it's not even human
the people who took the vaccine they're
not considered human anymore wait the
people who got the vaccine are no longer
human no and they're actually owned
they're enslaved by Pfizer or modern
whoever they took the shot from so
they're public they're their property
people who take the vaccine are owned by
Pfizer now and are not human Medics has
changed so they're not human anymore so
they're a borg Genesis that's owned by
Pfizer or their board Genesis that's
owned by and there you have it uh we are
in Laguna Hills talking to people
apparently if you've taken the vaccine
you are no longer human
resistance is futile
okay all right so listen this is you
know I don't it's fun to watch these
[__] chuckleheads do this
but this isn't just this one guy
standing outside whatever the hell
they're at some kind of protest or some
[__] who knows standing in the rain
um the these are your relatives these
are your community members that are
brainwashed by this [__] and if and if
people will believe this stuff you damn
well better believe that they're gonna
believe easily that Trump that Trump won
in 2020 and that he's some sort of
incumbent and that's why and that's why
this debate on tomorrow isn't gonna
[__] give any kind of evidence other
than Trump is going to be the nominee
um because of this kind of [__] this guy
thinks that if you got the vaccine
you're not human what the what the
actual [__] what in them yeah what in
the goddamn Monday Night Raw kind of
[__] is this
well I mean it's like Voltaire said man
um if you can get a man to believe
absurdities you can get him to commit
atrocities that that is the most famous
saying from the theological Voltaire I
mean he he and he hit it right on the
head because this guy I mean you've got
to understand and for folks that aren't
trekkies if you're not a Trekkie the
Borg that he's talking about the board
Genesis was a it's a fictional species
created within the Star Trek universe
and Gene rodderberry and they're writers
that took over for Gene Roddenberry when
and and and they created this fictional
species and and it's not just all humans
it's like aliens that are assimilated
and made half cyborg half that's where
the term Borg comes from their cyborg
half biological and this and this man
actually believes in his heart of hearts
if you look at the sincerity of his face
when he's speaking
and the intensity of what he's trying to
convince people that a fictional species
from a a a
you know Star Trek
sub-genre is actually what we have here
living on this planet because they took
a vaccine
it's wild [__] it's wild [__] you want
to show you let me show you something
else that's wild that's it yeah but I
mean think about what you can get that
guy to do Tony why I mean look at that
while we look at this think about what
you can get this guy these people to do
let me show you let me show you here's
you remember what was a couple years ago
they went down it was the anniversary of
John F Kennedy getting shot and they
went down to daily Plaza this Q Anon
cult and they thought that that Michael
Jackson or JFK Jr some [__] was gonna
appear down there at Daily Plaza right
JFK Jr right now this this that the the
the the sub leader of that Q Anon Trump
cult
um had a bunch of people held up in a
hotel
uh in Dallas right they were like peeing
in jars and drinking their own pee and
all kinds of weird [__] in this hotel
and he he like cut communication with
their family and everything this is like
a sub Trump cult so he's like us he's
like a lieutenant in the Q Anon Trump
cult but here that guy died apparently
uh judge of tick tock has this it says
there's a new leader of the q9 cult that
believes former President JFK and JFK Jr
are still alive
I believe this [__] after Michael
prodsman death earlier this year that's
the guy who held him up in the hotel
apparently uh people hoped the cult
would disband so like he would die and
then it would go away well we know um
based on cult's history that that's not
always generally what happens unless
everyone drinks a Kool-Aid that's how
David koresh took over his cult David
crash wasn't the original but still here
right exactly The Pavilions are still
here yeah right so here's here's what it
says at the end instead their new cult
leader is a 13 year old girl known as
Tiny Teflon tiny Teflon what in the
actual [__] when I read this and saw
this I was like no this can't be [__]
real can it nope that [__] is [__]
real it is [__] real here's here's a
um here's an a an excerpt uh while uh
protzman was the leader of the group he
introduced tiny Teflon in March of 2022
by featuring her on live chat in his
telegram channels this is a child album
this is this coming from save the
children queuing on [__] right
during the chat and subsequent
appearances the pair would use Gematria
to make links between everything between
the 2011 movie The Smurfs talking about
indoctrination and timing of Trump's
appearance in Home Alone 2 lost in New
York to conclude that Q's predictions
about the mass execution of child
trafficking cabal not to come true
it's known it's not known if there was
any uh family family connection between
prodsman and Tiny Teflon are how they
knew each other I wonder I wonder what
it could be Texas Paul I wonder what the
connection is to this grown-ass man cult
leader having a little girl as his
predecessor I wonder I wonder what it
could yeah no [__] right I mean that's
just disgusting but you've got to let me
know when we're gonna do these Tony I
don't have my red conspiracy string so
that I can you know make the links
between Q Anon and JFK Jr and the vice
presidency and then the 13 year old girl
and and of course they're all freaking
pedophiles I mean these people are
insane Tony they were standing outside
you know you talk about this they the
date passes right the time passes JFK Jr
doesn't show up
they stayed what wait wait a second man
I mean wait a second a lot of them
Christine Christine here on Facebook
saying she was his wife
are you [__] me is that real
is that [__] real because I didn't I
didn't know that I didn't know that I
was just presuming that the save the
children people were the ones that were
indoctrinating and grooming children
because that's how it normally goes we
see that day after day with these
[__] Church These pastors that speak
out against grooming and wokeism and
they end up being [__] child
molesters
um here here's another report from chuds
as we're talking about this tiny Teflon
is because this is crazy too has created
her own uh telegram channel uh has
conducted live streams of followers and
has announced her plan to indoctrinate
more children into the cult by teaching
them how to decode real world events
using the movements version of Geometry
this [__] wild [__] is that is that
real that she was his wife
is that [__] real
I have no idea on that one my friend I
haven't gone down that rabbit hole and
it's freaking gross
um I have no idea if they were
like married I I don't know well I mean
you can make assumptions about what the
relationship was what is a grown-ass man
being a a [__] cult leader bringing a
a little girl on his his to his side
acting like she's gonna be his
predecessor or some [__] come on
um you know that everyone's saying
Google it Google it and Susan brings up
a good point it's handmaid's tale this
is what these this is why they do this
[__] when you see someone like yelling
and screaming about [__] the lgbtq
committee oh by the way
um the guy in California that shot the
shot shop owner that [__] that
shot the shop owner I bet he has [__]
suppressed suppressed sexual feelings
and that's why the guy got so goddamn
scared listen to it go ahead and she she
wasn't even gay man she was just an ally
she just she was just a decent human
being
um
and this guy just I I just that whole
thing just wow man wow I mean there are
so many of these freaking Psychopaths
out there and that's I mean this
rhetoric matters man I sent you a link
there talking about the Smurfs and what
is this is this this guy is this the
same guy no this is real dude and he's
not alone man there are a lot of them
out there you remember during covid
um they pushed this conspiracy theory
especially through Q Anon that colloidal
silver
uh was the cure for
was the cure for covid well the whole
wait wait wait wait wait what the [__]
what what
I missed this the the you got to explain
this to me no people have been you have
been ingesting colloidal silver forever
man they just for some reason they think
it's this crazy ass gonna it's like it's
like the ancient the first Chinese
Emperor died drinking freaking Mercury
man you can't convince some people that
it's not real if you consume colloidal
silver
uh continuously this is what happens to
you I mean this is real this is
literally what happens to you you turn
balloon this ain't makeup
colloidal silver will turn you
physically and it doesn't go away dude
this dude is blue forever I mean it will
turn you freaking blue and they were
during covert they were just down in
this stuff as fast as they freaking good
because you know the horse Pace was
making them crap out their intestines so
they had to have something wow Hey Hey
listen the good news is the good news is
the Smurfs don't have worms that's the
good news right
God but that is the the conspiracy
theory is that
The Smurfs are communists
and they're indoctrinating children
are you talking about through the movie
or are the actual people who are taking
I'm talking about these people we're
talking about these people we're talking
these people who are standing out in
freaking Dallas waiting for JFK Jr
really believe that the Smurfs were
communist indoctrinate indoctrination of
your children
and then
covid was
sent out so that people would consume
colloidal silver
and turn into Smurfs
what in the actual [__]
what the Yeah listen I I I I I can't
tell you how much I
and I can't I think you're just making
this [__] up and here's the thing here's
the thing is is it is all made up you
may not be making this up for this show
but it is all made up it's all [__]
what the [__] yeah I believe this [__]
how could you could you how could you
use yourself my friend look up colloidal
silver in its effects man I'm not saying
I'm not saying that you're that you're
lying about this what I'm saying is is
this sounds like a bunch of hooey horse
[__] because it is a bunch of who we
horse [__] it is it is so is this is
this so this is not the guy this is not
the guy
um who the cult leader down and down no
no no no no not at all this is just some
example yeah this is guy that that
believed in this colloidal silver stuff
he was all over the Internet preaching
it to everybody and it's every every
disease that comes down the road they
March Out The Bottles of colloidal
Sovereign because America we have
freedom
um
oh it's dumb
idiot freedom dog [__] that's what it is
holy [__] Helen
uh well let me let me um let me back up
because this doesn't just stop at this
craziness uh about Q Anon now this I've
showed this before this lady is a manga
Prophet her name is Julie green and
apparently she gets emails from God now
when she says they're messages but this
[__] lady oh my God okay now the
reason why I gotta go down this road
Texas Falls because I got listen this
week is going to be a a stretch Because
by the time we get to the weekend people
in this country are going to go how in
the [__] are you still supporting Donald
Trump and this is why [__] this
is why it's a cult it's a cult it's a
God damn cult it has been for decades
the Republican party has been a cult for
a long time a long time they've been a
coach since before Trump this is long
before and they will be a cult after
Trump they are a [__] cult now this
again this lady named Julie green she
claims she's a prophet she claims she
receives messages from God I don't know
if she gets them in emails but let me
guess you should start on Tick-Tock I I
well I couldn't tell you but let me tell
you what I do know is these God emails
are [__] lit my friend holy [__]
they're lit listen to this crazy ass
[__]
indictments against my David are about
to explode
against so this is she's reading as if
God emailed her okay that's what she's
doing she got a message and she's just
reading it off now part of me wants to
believe that this lady's writing this
[__] making it up and part of me wants
to believe that someone has actually
convinced her that she's receiving email
from God okay and I actually believe the
second one is way more impossible than
the first one that she's not just making
sure she's talking to Elon Musk I do I
know a guy that he thinks that Elon Musk
has assumed another identity and is
texting him I am not kidding you what
wait like in your personal life you know
a guy in I in my personal life I know a
human being that believes communication
did he take the Pfizer vaccine because
we know if he took the visor vaccine
he's no longer a human being so you call
him a human being but he may not be he
may be one of them bored [__] things
or Genesis yeah he may be one of them
boards how do you keep track of this
[__] your life
you know what I mean
you know I got one of those weird
memories I mean no no no no I'm saying
50 years old like a room no I'm saying
if you're one of these people that gotta
make up all this [__] and they gotta
make up all this stuff about what's
going on and how it's going on how do
you keep track of what's real and what's
not like how do you compartmentalize
that [__] oh no no
sweet kid he really is sweet kid he's
not making this up he sincerely believes
that this person he's speaking to is is
Elon Musk and he's a he's a sweet kid he
just believes it you're just so so
what's that what what do you think how
do you think the person on the other
side of the line feels
they're having a [__] blast man
I I agree and I think the person writing
emails that got emails to this lady's
having a blast too listen to this is
wild [__] they will all
Fall Apart
Tucker Carlson is about to come out with
explosive evidence regarding Hunter
the Biden and Obama
Hunter the Biden I'm assuming she's
talking about Joe right so God God refer
now listen to this almighty all-powerful
God refers to Joe Biden as the Biden
that's incredible if you want to know
the honest truth I mean and really if
these emails are for God and God is
referring to Joe Biden as the Biden
doesn't that speak more to the shouldn't
that speak to these people I don't know
I'm just saying
Paul
I you know
um
it's just like an angel's Fear To Tread
situation because I mean you really I
mean
damn is she a grifter or is she really
freaking insane
right that's what makes it that's what
makes me want to listen to this lady and
makes me want to point it out to people
because really honestly she may have
started as a grifter but I think just
like Donald Trump is a grifter he
started to believe his own [__]
[__] and that's what the Republican
party has done is they have believed
their own [__] [__] for so long
that finally the cult is [__] drank
the delusional Kool-Aid listen to this
oh yeah some of them some of them are
really believe this those people did not
stand outside in the freaking heat in
Dallas waiting for JFK Jr
because they didn't believe I mean they
and these people are in your community
man that's the part that blows my mind
is you you see these like that guy that
in the first clip you showed that guy
is like a I don't know he's a contractor
somewhere or whatever he's coming in
your house installing some cabinets or I
mean he is around folks I mean he's
he's not just it's it's weird as [__]
speaking of weird ass [__] listen listen
to the rap up here that hasn't been
heard yet
their walls are crumbling and something
significant will take place
before the 2024 elections
that will rattle
this nation
my children get ready for a great change
that is coming to save you from what
your enemies were about to do next
again she looks like she's reading an
email now the thing that's significant
to me is she always has this in the
background it's a cat it's a calendar
and a clock right and I guess that's to
prove when she says this [__]
I I guess I I'm not really sure what
that weird ass thing's about but she's
always got the calendar clock in the
background what in the actual [__] is
wrong with these people and again I
first thought that she was a grifter
right I really believe this lady was a
grifter but I'm beginning to think she
started as a grifter and someone started
to email her and she started to believe
that this person emailing her was God
and she's reading these emails live on
air as they are from God it's weird as
[__] I'm not gonna lie it's [__] it's
crazy
yeah it's it's it's
you know man and and I really do think
that they start out as grifters I really
do I I think that that's it's like your
pastors and stuff and what they're just
they're shipping as as Drifters and
they're just trying bad to get a
following because a certain percentage
that follows the main and and they just
keep going people respond to it and I I
think that's how it starts but I think
you're absolutely right man they start
just you know getting high on their own
Supply they just
uh I don't know man I'm looking at this
woman and I'm thinking God she really
man she's really believing this
the only thing that makes me doubt that
is that you know where's the email
coming from you know I mean yeah well
that's I I don't know I don't know I
don't know how I don't know if she gets
like the letters in the mail or she gets
them uh in her email box I'm not really
sure
um it is it is it is really really
strange uh to watch this kind of stuff
now
um and speaking of strange
here is um Eric Trump on um on Newsmax
on Eric bolin's program this is weird
this is weird this makes me think that
um there's more indictments coming
especially for Eric Trump if you want my
personal opinion but oh listen listen to
this if somebody came into one of our
hotels while my father was President
they were from a foreign country a
government official from foreign country
and we found out about you know we do we
donate all the money for that you know
that Margarita that they bought at the
bar donated back to the United States
Treasury no you wouldn't you're so full
of [__] what the [__] okay so Eric Eric
Trump is on Newsmax now the the uh did
the aim here is to make the Biden crime
family you know that's that's what their
thing is is that they take a bunch of
money from foreign entities and he has
to explain to the Newsmax audience that
hey we we take a lot of foreign money
including including money that is bought
by liquor in our hotels right wink wink
he's telling you the [__] he's
telling you the game there that these
people come and they [__] they
patronize the the [__] Trump hotels
and and they're trading they're trading
stuff away but oh don't be rest assured
the money from that Margarita goes to
the United States Treasury which is all
a bunch of [__] the thing is it's
not a margarita it's a 30 000 per bottle
bottle service right exactly
well not only that but Banks of rooms
that no one else is renting uh I mean
yeah I mean you remember that they had
at the Trump Hotel they had the Saudis
had an entire empty floor there at one
point I mean just just the entire they
were renting an entire freaking floor of
the Trump Hotel and nobody was there I
mean it's just and they were paying you
know exorbitant amounts for these rooms
like four or five thousand dollars a
night I mean come on man this is this is
sophomoric [__] you don't need a a
brilliant prosecutor here to to to
realize this is Monday money laundering
going on man well again Eric Trump
bringing this up live on air makes me
think makes me think that Jack Smith has
uncovered some of this [__] especially
in the [__] wire fraud where he he
duped his supporters and stole their
money through credit card transactions
during the stop the steel [__] it in
2020 after the election when he lost and
he knew he lost but he he gathered up a
bunch of [__] speaking of griffs
gathered up a bunch of [__] money on
his supporters and never never used it
for his actual legal fund never used it
now he's using it now he's I think he I
think the other day it was 21 million
dollars is what the estimate is that
he's used isn't that funny they a
supposed billionaire they're giving him
five dollars ten dollars twenty dollars
they're [__] Mortgage in their houses
to give him money yeah and he's using 21
million dollars of his supporters money
and his legal effort and his criminal
his criminal Endeavors here and it's
[__] what this article you sent me
about the yeah the the image there the
van we were talking about these people
and and and you know the grifters but
you know on the other end of that you've
got the lady talking about the emails
but take a look at this van man that I
sent you yeah let me let me do that let
me get in on this thing yeah yeah no
worries that is Cesar Cesar sayox van
and if you don't remember who says or
sayak he was the remember the Trump pipe
bomber the one that sent sent bombs
around all around everybody
that's his van dude I mean that's what
he drove around in
and lived out of for a while you know so
you got email lady who's who's saying
this [__]
you know this is coming from God and I'm
talking to you and I'm telling you what
God wants and God has to say the other
end of that line
is people like Cesar sayak
I mean this guy is clearly insane he
mailed bombs out
um you know that that's the problem I
mean it's easy to sit and poke fun at
email lady you know and how stupid it is
and how stupid it is that people send
their money and stuff like that but this
guy right here is gonna you know he's
gonna kill some people before he's done
I mean he's gone to jail but when he he
hasn't stopped believing this cult
member believes man
you know and and it's a problem Tony
it's a real freaking Mental Health
crisis in this country well that that Q
Anon Shaman Jacob chansley Holy [__]
have you seen what kind of crazy that
guy's got into Jesus Christ the guy's
doing weird ass Joker videos and stuff
it's weird stuff like it's you would
think going to jail with his you know
everybody would hope to would straighten
him out oh no no he came out of jail
just encouraged and bat [__] crazier
than when he went in I know absolutely
absolutely well and here's this guy this
is the guy this is the guy um let's see
if I'm bringing a beer on the screen
this is the guy Travis how do you say it
a Gucci
Gucci yeah right this is the guy who
killed um the shop owner there in
California this is a post
um I guess this is it is Twitter
his Twitter account and this is from
this isn't like years ago if you look at
the date here this is from June 13th
what to do with the lgbtqp flag
he wants to burn it hmm and he shot
someone over it so so this idea that oh
man that bigotry just lives on social
media it can it can manifest into real
life
and you know it was pinned to his
account you saw that right I mean that
was that was something he was highly
highly proud of I mean he wanted
everybody that came to his account to
see you know that that you know and what
what is going on in oligaguchi's life
that he has such a problem with who
other people are sleeping with you know
I mean you know think about that I mean
what what's going on in this guy's life
that that that is something that is just
causes him to have violent well I'll
tell you he doesn't want his bro friends
his bro friends to know that he's gay
that's what that's what he want that he
doesn't want his bro friends to know
he's gay so he overcompensates just like
just like the guy down in Dallas who
recruits the 13 year old girl to be his
predecessor apparently some people are
saying I don't know what to tell you
some people are saying that Shan it
might have been his wife but it seems a
little suspicious that the save the
children guy is recruiting children to
to indoctrinate other children just
seems kind of weird uh you want to talk
about you want to talk about a domestic
terrorist here's one running for
congress that's right Derek I called you
a domestic terrorist you [__] piece
of [__] Derek evidence trying to run for
Congress in West Virginia
um now this is a picture of Derek
getting out of federal prison a lot of
times guys that leave federal prison
look like this they got black boots on
those are federal prison issue pants
um and then his sweatsuit you know
but here's here's what Derek has to say
on Twitter oh this is hmm man it is just
what a [__] idiot all the Liberals
saying Insurrection you should go to
prison yeah you are all going to prison
been there done that and had the
sweatsheet to prove it okay thanks he
says release from prison in October well
good for you he says I'm now I'm a
former January 6th political prisoner
you're not a political prisoner running
for U.S Congress that's right he's
running for congressional seat folks he
says I'm going to win follow this up
Texas Paul and I'm going to seek
retribution now I thought this is what
got Derek in prison in the first place
if you want to know the honesty when
when when this [__] sore loser their
their orange Mussolini Jesus their cult
leader lost the election and they
couldn't accept the [__] results so
you went to seek retribution that the
United States capital
on Mike Pence and the Congress for
certifying the results which was their
job that day to certify the results for
Joe Biden it seems like it seems like
that that Derek here believes so many
things but the thing he truly believes
is that he really is a domestic
terrorist why else would he say Texas
Paul that he's seeking retribution that
is he's not he's not running he's not
running the set policy Texas Paul he's
not running to change policy on the
Department of Transportation or make
schools better or make health care more
affordable in this country he's running
to seek retribution Texas Paul this
sounds to me like a domestic terrorist
if you want to know yeah and my first
question is uh was he released on parole
because if he was this is a violation of
it I mean he he needs to go back to
prison
um likely he's done with it because like
I said
he's probably done with his paper and he
probably only had I'm not sure of his
sentence
but you know this this will actually
serve in his next sentencing won't it I
mean he he didn't learn a damn thing
when he went to prison and he's very
proud of it so yeah folks this is these
are the people we're talking about I
mean they they're they're trash they've
been trash he tells you he's trash he
tells you that he's a he he's a a
terrorist he tells you he wants to you
know everybody in the world to know it
and more importantly
your average Republican voter is trashed
just like he is they're going to go out
and they're going to vote for this guy
just as a big middle finger
just to say we can
so yeah that's why you have to get out
to vote in every damn election we're
literally fighting terrorists in The
Ballot Box I mean it's
it's that simple
it's that simple Kalina makes a good
point here on YouTube as he said he
should be disqualified and I think
actually it makes a good case for every
single one of the January 6 defendants
who receive prison time to be 14th 100
full stop just 14th them federal judges
should start 14th in these [__]
immediately
um and prevent them from ever being part
of any government anywhere I don't give
a [__] if it's City counts all the way
down to the goddamn dog catcher they
shouldn't have anything to do with
setting policy in this country if they
have proven that they're they're willing
to overthrow our government or any
government for that matter and
especially when he's talking about on
Twitter how he's gonna seek his run for
office is to seek retribution
seek retribution on who his constituents
by representing them it's really [__]
weird Texas Paul but you call them human
trash and speaking of human trash look
at Charlie Kirk here here's the guy you
probably incited the [__] terrorists
who shot up who shot up the the lady in
California in her clothing store yes
Charlie Kirk I'm saying there's blood on
your hands same way with Ben Shapiro
Matt Walsh and and the like at Daily
wire oh don't don't mention Nick Fuentes
as well but here's Charlie Kirk talking
to Nick Sora or uh what's his name Nick
something he's on Twitter he's been in
these Mario and Mario's [__] Twitter
spaces but we Shuffle yeah yeah we
showed a uh
we showed a video of Nick yesterday in
Maui and and someone came up to him in
Maui and was like Hey man and Nick got
really scared he got really frightened
that this guy approached him and asked
him a question but here's Charlie Kirk
talking about how Nick was scared that
someone approached him I'm sure this is
not to cuck central USA but let's find
out
whoa
so here you are trying to report the
news and you get hunted down at 5 45 in
the morning by a Luna no Charlie no no
stop [__] he wasn't hunted down
the lady in California was hunted down
because of people like you saying [__]
like you say
Nick was approached by a person a blue
check more than likely on X saying hey
Nick why are you taking up resources in
Hawaii why are you doing that but as an
investigative journalist he's not a
journalist by the way Nick's not a
journalist he's not one he's not one but
Charlie he's not being hunted down
you're encouraging people to hunt down
liberals you're the one encouraging
people to hunt down the lgbtq community
and their allies that's what you're
doing Nick's not being hunted here he's
just being asked questions but let's
continue lunatic Hawaiian
Nick I I've never seen anything like
this you're you're trying to help Nick
tell us about it
truly the victim Texas fall these
right-wingers truly are always the
victim there's not much left in the clip
but what do you make of Charlie biting
his pin
um being so oh man you were hunted oh
man it must have been see you're such a
victim isn't it isn't it just the Manga
victimhood Here
yeah that's what he does all the time I
mean he'll he'll say some outrageous
[__] and then he'll go to speak
somewhere every one of his appearances
it's the same damn thing same damn stick
he'll go out there he'll say something
ridiculous and outlandish so people will
protest then he comes out and and he
videotapes himself standing in front of
the people protest protesting uh and
then he tells his people that he's a
real tough guy and not scared of these
people and he's a victim it's the same
stick over and over and over again he's
just trying to do it with this jackass
who went to freaking Maui for no damn
reason he's not a legitimate news Outlet
all he did was take up time and
resources which is exactly what the
people of Maui ask people not to do they
said you know we've we've got a problem
here people stay away we need every bit
of resources available to the locals to
to to get people's safe housing standing
that hotel room he was taking up had it
been an empty hotel room they could have
probably put it Maui citizen in you know
to to give them some freaking shelter I
mean these people are just
they're human trash they're human trash
well and they speak fluent victims as
Jeffrey points out here on YouTube they
speak fluent victims because that's
actually the question that was asked him
we watched the video yesterday but the
guy approaches him and says hey Nick you
said you were gonna actually stay in a
tent but you're not you're not staying
in a tent where are you staying and he
was trying to ask Nick live on air when
he was on Steve bannon's show now Steve
Bannon threw him to the Wolves which was
fantastic but let's see if Charlie here
throws him to the Wolves I highly doubt
it other part about it is yes this was 5
45 a.m but this was also directly behind
my hotel that was wait he's he said he
was going to stay in a tent I thought
but he says his hotel which means he did
take up a room Texas ball 45 minutes
away from Lahaina and they were able to
track me there and I guess they were
waiting for me I I I I don't know the
guy just appeared behind me I never
heard a car pull up I never heard uh you
know any movement until he was right
behind me it was the weirdest thing I've
ever can I clarify something yeah go
ahead
I speak publicly I do and when I go to
speak publicly or I go to doing I tell
people where I'm going right if you go
there and see me you haven't tracked me
down right I told you where I was gonna
be I mean
you know this guy he's trying to act
like somebody you know putting air tags
in his good freaking luggage or
something like that it's bull he told
anybody and everybody who would listen
I'm here I'm here pay attention to me
and then now he's sitting on tweeted it
he tweeted it he [__] said the whole
world come on man yeah and he's sitting
there with Charlie Kirk doing exactly
what you're talking about I was so
nervous and scared I didn't see him
coming he asked me a question those
assault questions look the normal
questions the normal questions they'll
kind of they might injure you right they
might injury it could kill you but those
are solve questions oh my God those
assault questions yeah
was it a high capacity assault question
I mean it would work were there 30
questions in the magazine or was it a
drum of 100 questions it was it was it
was it was quite scary when I watched
the video I was actually scared for Nick
I mean could you imagine me telling
everybody where I'm at and then somebody
came to ask me something I mean I oh
the humanity I just
uh Nick you certainly are a [__] ass
[__] now which leads me to what I want
to talk about for the most of the
remainder of the show is what's going to
happen tomorrow night because there's
going to be a lot of predictions out
there and a lot of them are going to be
a dead [__] wrong I believe my
prediction is going to be spot on but I
want to show you
um first Chris Christie here talking
about Donald Trump and uh the Georgia
himself turning himself in under 200
bail Chris Christie is going to be on
the stage tomorrow and I think there's a
significant listen she's a coward
there's no weather conclusion comes to
that he's both afraid of me and he's
afraid of Defending his record
and if I had his record I'd be nervous
about showing up too I mean let's face
it guys by Wednesday he's going to be
out on bail in four different
jurisdictions
that really when are we gonna stop
thinking that's normal but if you know
allow our country to understand again
that nominating someone who's out on
bail in four jurisdictions is not a
winning formula okay so first off Chris
Christie says exactly what I said he
would say I said Chris Christie would
say the reason why Donald Trump is not
on the stage is because he's scared of
Chris Christie which is the [__]
truth Texas Paul the only reason why
Donald Trump decided not to go to that
debate is because Chris Christie's going
to be on that stage that's why
absolutely 100 percent absolutely Chris
Christie has been funded by an old
school Republican that said I don't care
where you come in I don't care what your
polling is you just keep firing those
16-inch guns at Donald Trump and telling
the truth
[Music]
and no matter what happens to the day
this election runs if they nominate
Trump the to the day this election
happens Chris Christie will be blowing
holes in him just to make sure Trump
does not have a second term that is his
mission that is his paid Mission and you
know as far as people like Chris
Christie and and and and
these other right-winger kinsinger and
all these folks you know I I don't like
them I don't agree with them I don't
know anything but I'm glad they're doing
what they're doing I am glad they're
doing what they're doing
well uh now the thing that is
significant about Chris Christie being
on the stage and the reason why I bring
it up where I brought it up because Nick
was crying that someone approached him
do you think and I think we could have
this moment
in in this week we can have this clip
where Chris Christie makes Ron DeSantis
cry on stage I almost bet because
because Chris Christie's not going to
have Trump there to punch on Chris
Christie is going to beat the ever 11
[__] out of Lauren DeSantis Rhonda
Santos has no clue what's coming and
Rhonda santis should have really really
really considered not showing up to this
debate as well and the reason why is
because of Chris Christie but I want to
show you a clip of what Rhonda santis
keeps saying here lately and I think
this is one place where where uh Chris
Christie can absolutely beat the ever
loving [__] adirondo Santos on this part
of crossing the border and shooting them
shooting them just for crossing
imaginary line listen to this they're
not even trying to take fentanyl it gets
in it and it's fatal and it's wrong that
Biden is not lifting a finger to stop
this so when I get in we are gonna make
sure to use lethal Force against the
Mexican drug cartels
when they try if they try to bring the
fence and all across the southern border
when I am President we are going to
shoot him stone cold dead
pro-life Pro [__] life Texas Paul God
damn that's a pro-life stance if I've
ever heard one what a [__]
chucklehead and let me tell you
something if Chris Christie doesn't
attack Ron DeSantis on this point he's a
feckless coward too feckless coward if
Ron if Chris Christie can't muster up
enough [__] courage to absolutely
destroy Ron DeSantis on stage in front
of the American people on this point he
he will never Chris Christie will never
be president of the United States
and if I were Chris Christie I would say
this you know this just just shows how
stupid you are this shows how little you
understand law enforcement or the
subject of drug smuggling because it's
been proven statistically we know that
80 to 90 percent of the drugs smuggled
into this country are smuggled in by
American citizens for American citizens
so what you are telling me and and
everyone else that can hear is that you
intend to summarily execute American
citizens without due process that is
exactly what you were saying explain to
me how that works you're telling me if
they have fentanyl in their backpack
we're going to leave them cold dead okay
so what you're telling me is you're
going to have law enforcement Customs
and Border Patrol agents because the
vast majority of the drugs smuggled into
this country come through legal ports of
Entry you are going to have a Customs
and Border Patrol agent
find drugs on an individual pull that
individual out of their vehicle or pull
them off the sidewalk and you're dead
execute them that is what you are
telling us your policy is you freaking
[__]
if Chris Christie does not attack him on
this point if he does not attack
tomorrow night on this point folks you
goddamn well better bet I'm going to
keep after Chris Christie's ass from now
until the end of time if Chris Christie
doesn't muster up enough courage to
attack him on this point this is an easy
point for Chris Christie to attack and
to win to win the the he's not going to
win the primary he's not going to win
support from Maga but what what Chris
Christie can do is divide the Republican
party so Trump can't win and I believe
that's what Chris Christie's mission is
here I think that's what he's going to
do and I hope whoever's funding him
keeps funding him all the way through to
the very [__] end even if he doesn't
win one goddamn delegate I hope Chris
Christie keeps at it and keeps dividing
the Republican party and this is a
position point that I think
the majority of manga believes and they
want because they're a cult of hate and
they want to kill they want to kill
anyone that's brown coming across the
border because Texas Paul what you said
about the facts manga doesn't know what
you said about the facts DeSantis knows
that manga doesn't know that they don't
know that fentanyl comes from legal
ports of Entry they don't know that the
majority of fentanyl is coming across
the border with Americans not with
[__] but not with citizens or or
Mexican people it's coming across the
border by with American citizens and
legal ports of entry and their and the
Biden Administration has actually caught
more fentanyl coming through those ports
of Entry than the Trump Administration
has so DeSantis is [__] lying to
these people he's trying to get them to
think that the little kids that are
coming across the border
that are migrating here uh to be
refugees and their families to make a
better life for themselves to become
American citizens to become part of
American culture to be the hard-working
Americans that we need in the future to
advance our democracy and our country
and our nation and our national security
he's wanting them to believe that
they're going to pop them off as they
climb over the wall that's what he wants
them to believe is we will shoot any
brown person in sight that is climbing
over a wall we will shoot to kill and we
will shoot on site because don't get it
twisted Ronda Santos is one of the
[__] who is torturing people
down at gitmo and standing there
laughing while they're torturing them so
when he says this [__] he knows he's
lying but he's being dead [__]
serious about it if he could he would
kill [__] so would Trump so
would the rest Republican party and if
Greg Abbott Rhonda santis and Trump
hasn't proven that yet then you aren't
paying attention you're just not [__]
paying paying attention they're [__]
paying attention [__] he just said it
Tony right exactly set it right out of
his mouth I'm gonna kill
people crossing the border that's what
I'm gonna do no trial no anything you're
an American citizen carrying a backpack
full of drugs we're not going to arrest
you try you send you to prison we're
gonna shoot you that's what he's saying
and and and and everybody that votes
Republican those sorry pieces
trash individuals are also they're like
freaking seals in a show
you know I mean they're they're garbage
Tony they're freaking garbage human
beings that's why I tell people all the
time you better stop sending me that
stuff I will start blocking you when I
say we are better people than they are
and you send me [__] in my comments it
says you can't say that Paul
[__] I can and it's the truth it is
the truth Rhonda Santos is a piece of
human trash and anyone anyone who
supports him or backs him is a piece of
human trash let me show you let me show
you on Newsmax this represented Mark
um Alfred it's from Missouri it's a
shame that this guy is a [__] elected
official but this is the kind of [__]
you're gonna hear about Joe Biden on
stage tomorrow night folks listen I'd be
okay if Joe Biden went on Permanent
Vacation uh just a question did you
catch it did you catch it Texas Paul
let's listen I couldn't hear it
went all permanent thank you thank you
uh just a question
he'd be okay if Joe Biden went on
Permanent Vacation that's what we're
gonna hear tomorrow night on the stage
listen
I'd be okay if Joe Biden went on
Permanent Vacation I wonder what that
means I wonder if he means like I don't
know uh to the beach or something they
don't like when he goes to the beach
they hate that so let's forget about
that they they lose their minds when Joe
Biden shows up at the beach and takes
his shirt off they [__] hate that so
they probably won't do that maybe he'll
go bicycling uh on vacate no they don't
like that either when he goes bicycling
they really don't [__] like maybe you
know what maybe maybe he'll go to church
a lot you know that's probably not the
thing that he's talking about uh though
Texas
oh they [__] and hate when he goes to
church they [__] hate it let's see
what where else could Joe Biden go on
vacation
um permanently that permanently right
that this guy is talking about what what
could he possibly mean what could he buy
and we're wondering why a guy showed up
at a [__] clothing store in
California and shot the shop owner for
hanging a [__] rainbow flag in her
[__] business and we're wondering how
that happens we're wondering how guy
shows up at Nancy Pelosi's house and
smashes her husband in the [__] head
with a hammer we're wondering how that
[__] happens the [__] out of here
we're wondering why Craig Robertson and
Utah threatened to [__] kill shooting
kill and assassinate the president
United States and when the FBI shows up
the server search warrant he [__]
shoots at him and gets himself killed by
suicide by cop we're wondering where
this all comes from I wonder where it
could [__] possibly come from where
these ideas can enter in these [__]
idiots brains hmm I wonder could it be
Rhonda this talking about shooting and
killing people coming across the border
dead on site could it be the [__]
Congressman here Alfred from Missouri
talking about how Joe Biden's gonna go
on Permanent Vacation I think the Secret
Service should show up at Mr Alfred's
office and [__] interview his dumb
ass could you imagine Tony for one
second how the little local freaking
County Sheriff would react up in
Missouri if I showed my ass up there and
said yeah I'm here to say no Alfred on a
permanent vacation oh yeah oh yeah and
his office would be writing letters to
that sheriff to have him [__]
arrested he came and threatened
oh
I didn't sitting with Charlie Kirk
they'd be sitting with Charlie Kirk okay
I never saw him coming with him oh my
God my hat
I mean it's just they're freaking trash
Tony they're trash they're I mean it's
not just this elected [__] it's their
voters they're trash people Tony they're
horrible human beings man they'll sit
there and they'll hear that and say yeah
oh yeah that's tough I like that let's
send him some money and then I swear to
God if I showed up in Missouri I'm gonna
send an offered on a permanent vacation
I'd have no problem with that
they would be what did he say
what did he say oh my God I mean the
victims the victories would be would be
fluent and it's always with the
victories with these people they're
always the victims when they're the
perpetrators here here's another example
here's another example of a [__]
speaking victimies here's [__] here's
uh the Hercules what's his name Kevin
sarbos what the hell is his name here
yeah Sorbo listen to this motherfucker's
victimies just divide in our country
right now and it's perpetuated by the
mainstream media professionally the
movies TV
um I don't Harbor that kind of anger and
hate towards people [__] yeah my
imagination for so many years that we
can't get your jobs anymore I work with
you because people you know because if
you're being a Christian be conservative
and I
I almost had to laugh at that because
it's an industry that screams for
tolerance and yet it's a one-way Street
it screams for freedom of speech but
it's Hollywood's one-way Street as well
that's that's just too bad you're not a
Christian and you're not a conservative
Sorbo that's not what you are you're not
either of those things and that's not
why they're that's not why they're not
giving you jobs it's because you're a
[__] nut job and you won't shut your
[__] mouth on social media you won't
you won't quit with the cult of hate and
there's one thing that business doesn't
like especially nowadays is when you're
in the cult of hate because they can't
predict what the [__] stupid [__] you're
gonna Post online sarbo and again it's
just more victimies oh I'm the victim I
said crazy [__] online and that's why
they won't give me jobs
Chachi moved from California yet I mean
it was like the fourth time Chachi
threatened to to move from from
California because you know dude man I
don't know
I used to watch Happy Days a lot I'm I'm
feeding you full of a line of [__] I
I know who Chachi is but I know he
speaks fluent victims too that's why
they all love Trump is because he allows
them to be the worst version of
themselves right he allows them to be
that worse version of themselves but not
only that he allows them to perpetuate
their grift with victimhood and it's
[__] nuts if this guy listen if this
guy wasn't shot and killed by the
authorities in California after he shot
and killed that shop owner oh he'd be oh
man I was impressed that's why I was
impressed I went in her shop and I felt
oppressed by a flag you know oh it but
he's probably one of these freedom of
speech boys just like [__] Sorbo oh
freedom of speech freedom of speech
freedom freedom and liberty but not
Freedom uh way that I want that you want
to live Freedom the way that I want you
to live you get freedom religion and
what I mean by that is you have the
freedom to to adopt my religion only
that's your [__] Freedom that's what
these people white Christian
nationalists believe so [__] Sorbo [__]
DeSantis [__] Congressman Alford from
Missouri [__] all these [__] victims
yeah I love that Meme that goes around
talking about that Tony that says uh uh
your religion limits you not me right
and it limits your behavior not mine
yeah I mean they can't ever figure you
know and they know they know they know
that what they're all about they know
it's about you know any kind of power
they can get their hands on any way they
can try to control somebody you know to
they're just shitty human beings Arcola
I couldn't remember chachi's last name
Chachi Arcola yeah I had to look it up
it was bothering me
but anyway
has he moved yet though I mean and the
last time I saw he was he was really hot
and upset that you know California
wouldn't you know we're canceling them
and it's
wow big Scott Baio need out there I mean
do you
what state
wants Scott Baio to move to their state
I mean they're like please move to my
state I mean is there a state that
actually wants him to move
well I mean they want they want any kind
of brainless sheep to move to Florida
for sure I mean that's kind of their
[__] they're gonna open up a bar there
and sell Bud Light
[Laughter]
ah did you hear you know what um why
we're speaking about like did you see
that kid rock is the back on Bud Light
again
he's back on the Bud Light wagon yeah
man the camera wasn't on him so you know
he was just being him just standing
there on the balcony just sucking him
down
I guess no you know he ever stopped
drinking Bud Light I don't think he's
not thinking about it no the reason he
had a case of Bud Light to shoot in the
first place because he's got a whole
damn pile of them in his damn garage man
I mean
you know that dude hangs with bikers
right
uh Kid Rock
yeah he really does he's got like a
biker gang that he's a he's a uh last I
heard he was an initiative but yeah he
parties with a whole damn biker gang
thing and they just you know sorry for
taking a left turn there but no no no no
well but really he does man
see do you think the biker gang their
favorite beer is Bud Light that's why he
had so much of it to shoot up
yeah exactly what I'm saying exactly
what I'm saying he keeps the house stock
to party with his biker friends and
before all that happened you know they
were Big Bud Light Drinkers and they
said and as soon as the camera went off
and you know hey they got beer in the
garage you think they're not going to
drink it I mean you know right
what you gonna do we're gonna shoot it
all
bikers you know what you know what I'm
talking about these guys that are like
lawyers and teachers and [__] and they
buy a Harley and they're like Weekend
Warriors you know and they they buy the
leather jackets they start a club they
have a clubhouse they're you know
they're posers right they want to think
that they're really tough in this sort
of [__] but they're not they're not
tough they're dentist they're
orthodontist they're you know there's
these soft [__] these soft
white [__] that wish wish they
would have had a life of on the road on
a Harley you know banging women and
doing drugs right that's that's their
image that's their mindset and their
Weekend Warriors and their posers right
so do you are you saying it's that kind
of biker gang or it's like the Hell's
Angel type biker gang because there's no
he he really does yeah you can Google it
he really does party and hang out
there's a gang he hangs out with it all
right Club pardon me a club I call it
shouldn't call them gang they're Club
well they're a club
but who does it just to party with them
I mean he's not hard dude he's not out
there trying to get into the business
that's what I want to get at here do you
think someone who's so secure uh that's
in a biker Club a real one not no
[__] poser weekend warrior [__] I'm
talking about a real [__] biker Club
a guy who lives on his goddamn Harley
right in his leather Champs and on his
Harley that's how he lives out of his
saddlebags let me ask you do you think
that guy gives two shits about what any
anybody says about the beer he wants to
drink he's gonna [__] drink it rather
it doesn't matter who the [__] says what
about on the internet about beer he's
gonna drink the beer he wants that guy
doesn't give a [__] what the internet
says about a beer right and that's the
point is the poser group of bikers the
posers are like yeah that [__] will turn
you gay and the real bikers like look
I'll turn you gay [__]
look look you know man I I hate to throw
this out there I happen to know if you
legit
hardcore bikers I do right and I will
tell you you know what they aren't
loud Mouse right they are not they they
they they don't want a big scene they
don't want attention no because they're
taking care of their business and their
business doesn't mix well with attention
you know what I mean they just they're
quiet they're they you know and and
they're
no [__] and I'm not preaching for bikers
here I'm not because it's a misogynistic
shitty way to live but in my personal
opinion but you know they love it they
do it they do their things just that and
the other but they you know they'll do
[__] like they will really legit Toys
for Tots man I mean they will legit you
know they're all about not having to
worry about your family at home this
idea so somebody like Kid Rock's like
you're drinking a Bud Light Are You
Queer would likely eat that can of Bud
Light and it would be quick fast quiet
it would be and then down and then walk
away you know I mean it wouldn't be like
Santa oh it was tough I kicked these ass
but you never hear a biker do that it's
whoop ass and go you know I mean you
know I mean they're not like that
they're not like [__] Kid Rock and
his pay attention to me I'm shooting
some Bud Light cans because you know
deep inside I I really thought she was
pretty well she was pretty I got another
example of someone being a tough guy or
pretending to be a tough guy you
remember a guy named uh Ted Nugent he
had one good song fever and one good
song but a lot of people man they're
giving him [__] here lately about uh all
the the collection of dildos that this
guy has have you seen this
this is on his podcast he's getting he's
Ken he's got mountains of dildos on his
dresser I don't know man it just I don't
know to me it just feels like that a guy
who wants to project his masculinity
um doesn't normally you know I'm not
against dildos I'm not against it if a
guy wants to use a deal whatever you
want to do you know it's your life but
for a guy who projects his masculinity
like Ted Nugent does here it's kind of
weird that he's got this and it's not
like
uh it's not like these are small Texas
balls no
these are these are not these are not
like um you know these are not your
executive size these are not your white
collar size these are not party favors
these are not party favors these are the
party that will give you a favor okay
these
with him in this clip no no no there's a
there's another uh are you talking about
that dildo because that that scene does
have a huge dildo uh are you talking
about Rittenhouse Matt that is a big
deal though uh no I guess I guess
Rittenhouse win on his show uh but he
was not the only dildo that appeared on
his show and Ted decided to have his
entire collection out on his dresser and
a lot of people you know yeah Tony it's
like if you have a car and you give it a
name
right I mean vessels vehicles are
yeah right right they call it she's
right I don't care if you're on the USS
Ronald Reagan when they talk about the
Ronald Reagan they say chi right she
same thing with pickup trucks and you
know you get all these hillbilly boys
from around here they have their pickup
trucks and then they hang truck nuts on
the back
they have transgender trucks
wait wait wait they have creams do you
think that's what's going on in this
picture in this podcast with Ted Nugent
is he's trying to tell us
oh yeah yeah
oh yeah I don't know I'm just trying to
figure this out I think it's weird
number one he looks like [__] doesn't he
God damn hate hate will just do a number
on you it really will he looks like
death to be quite honest he looks like
get killed over or death dildoed over I
don't know I don't know what he does
with these in his first life really
frankly I I you know what Ted honestly
man if this floats your boat
get her just like Texas Paul said it's a
her get her if it floats your boat get
her done get her done
oh my God
so you're saying
you just want to reiterate this you're
saying that all these trucks with like
the Trump flags on them and [__] they
got the they got the um that the
American flags and they got the truck
nuts those are transgender trucks
absolutely absolutely are you telling us
surgery is that what you're saying no
but think about it all these guys they
lift these trucks up they put these
shiny wheels on them they put the wraps
on them what are you doing when you're
doing that Tony you're accessorizing
that's true you're accessorizing and wow
right that they love most is the truck
notes so I'm getting starting to
understand all the transgender hate
because they are like
how dare you put Dylan Mulvaney on my
Bud Light because she really makes me
feel funny
isn't that the truth though that's the
truth they look at Dylan Mulvaney and
the reason why they're so pissed off is
because they kind of get a semi when
when they see Dylan when they see her
they get confused and they're like well
she kind of gives me you know feelings
butterflies down there my britches and
that's what really pisses me off is that
I get confused because I see a woman I
want a woman but something deep down
inside me says I might be I might be gay
if I like this woman so how does that
compete with the truck nuts though it's
it's got to be the same thing right is
is that their truck is a she and they
just can't drive a [__] Chi they just
can't have it to where they're they're
come on man you're from Missouri you've
seen these guys when they get out there
they take their shirts off they start
washing their trucks and then they get
the part with the nuts and they just
slowly wait wait do you think
I'm out driving around watching finding
these guys in their driveways
in their Speedos washing their trucks
uh and and scrubbing their truck nuts is
that what you think you got this down
the training partner you know you don't
know why you got a cannon parlor in your
little town Who the hell's using it you
know it's trucked out the sky oh the
truck guts my truck nuts guy with the
Trans truck is using the tanning parlor
you can't make this [__] up with its
high-heeled boots and I hate to say it
yeah and his and his hat
right you know they're all out there and
with their fancy clothes on with their
little Pearl snaps their Bejeweled jeans
you've seen those they're the jewel
jeans yeah I mean you've seen them right
that's why this they're having so much
hate man because it's like
feel
so much like I want to go watch
Brokeback Mountain again
oh my God they're in the closet dude
they just cannot deal with their own
sexuality they cannot deal with their
own sexuality they can't do it and
that's the whole point man I know I'm
making some jokes here folks this at the
other at people's expenses this that and
the other but really a lot of this a lot
of this
what terrifies these people especially
the churches is that as we become more
and more comfortable with everybody just
dealing with their own sexuality hey man
you just be you you just be you Tony if
you like them dildos on Nugent stressor
I'm cool with it man I'm you know [__]
whatever you know makes you happy dude
but the more people get comfortable the
more people get comfortable and they
come out and they just do their own
thing and the number of people young
people that are identifying AS lgbtqia
Plus is skyrocketing it used to be
something like four percent now
total and now it's like 20 percent and
and it's terrifying these people you got
the trucking us people out there that
are that are just
you know they they can't deal with
what's happening All That was supposed
to stay in the closet Tony
nobody was supposed to know well I don't
know that Ted Nugent here keeps his
dildos in his closet he puts them on his
dresser apparently that's where he likes
to keep them so and where we like to
keep you is here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific it's always a pleasure
Texas Paul having you on the show
tomorrow Texas Paul has a show on
Wednesday go to realtexaspaul.com link
is down below go to realtexaspaul.com
follow him on YouTube go check out his
show tomorrow and on Sundays also if you
want to get in the chat 24 7 go to
Discord the link is going to be in the
chat in just a second as soon as I copy
and paste it here
um you can go join the Discord you can
get listen the chant continues like
crazy over on the Discord server so
you're not going to want to miss it even
if you got to download Discord it ain't
hard to figure out I promise I can do it
and I I do do it but also subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast here on
YouTube don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button you're not going to
want to miss a single episode
as we go every single week especially
this week this week's going to be a big
week it's going to be a huge week I got
Tennessee Brando coming on sometime this
week we're going to talk about this new
song what we're going to talk about yeah
we're going to talk about a few other
musical things
and break down the cult of music that
they have going on over there amazing I
mean he can sit down he can sit down and
the time it takes me to butter toast he
can write a song man it's amazing and it
is amazing his song tastes good just as
good as butter toast uh ever will so I'm
hoping we'll have him on either tomorrow
or Thursday I think is when we're going
to get Tennessee Brando on so uh don't
don't go anywhere and don't make sure to
watch every single show this week again
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central on YouTube Twitter Facebook and
twitch you can follow us on Twitch at
twitch.tv Tony Michaels everyone you can
find all the links everywhere at the
tonymichaels.com until tomorrow because
tomorrow will come and tomorrow is going
to be the debates in the evening and
then Thursday we get an arrest with the
debate pickup don't go anywhere we'll
see you then same time same place Surf's
Up [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon